I was asked a question
from chat GPT
interesting
so I'll tell you although I suspect you
probably can get an equally good answer
from chat GPT
the most important principle is about
what I call the Holy Grail of investing
and that's about diversification
what it means is
in a nutshell I could describe it as if
you can get 10 or 15 good uncorrelated
Investments you can reduce your risk by
up to 80 percent without reducing your
return that means you increase your
return to risk ratio by a factor of five
risk reduction is really key so uh it's
how it's a know-how to diversify well in
the area of 10 or 15 Investments if you
can do that then you will make a fortune
because making a fortune is not just a
matter of The Upside it eliminates or
reduces the downside so you continue to
play the game a lot of people think that
the way you make a lot of money is to
come up with the best single or a few
bets
that's wrong that approach to the game
will knock you out of the game you'll
have one terrible situation
mind that what you don't know is greater
than what you do know and so the power
of diversification is a really great
power so I'd like you to understand what
are you good at what do you know and
what don't you know and then how do you
diversify well to have a good return
relative to your risk that's the most
important principle